من موسكو الى الغرب ابقوا بعيدين عن
الداخل الروسي والا فستندمون اشد الندى
وبوتات طعنون في ظهرنا ولن نسمح بانقسام
روسيا وسنحمي شعبنا الدخل الروسي يشتعل
اكثر وطباخ بوتين اعيد واكرر تنبيه الجميع
سنسحق كل من يقف في طريقنا والرئيس
الشيشاني يتدخل بالاف المقاتلين وبولندا
تترقب وتعلن حاله التاهب القصوى واردوغان
اول زعيم اجنبي يمد يد العون لموسكو فاجنر
تقطع طريق امداد العمليات في اوكرانيا
امام بوتين 48 ساعه وهو بين خيارين
الانفجارات تطال الاراضي الروسيه والطائره
تتساقط وفي ختام عاصفه الاحداث هذه كلها
اعلنت فاغنر نهايه الفيلم البوتيني القصير
والمليء بالمغامره فهل هي خدعه ام ان
المخرج قال ستار
حيله خبيثه
فجاه وتوني سابقي انذار القوات تتجه الى
الداخل الروسي بدلا عن التحرك نحو
اوكرانيا ما هذا الذي يجري الحشود تنسحب
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه نحو الاراضي
الروسيه امر لم يخطر على بالي اشد
المتشائمين الروس ولم يحلم به اكبر
المتفائلين من الغرب واوكرانيا بعد ان
اعلن مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر
والملقب بطباخ ان الجيش الروسي وجه ضربه
لقواته ها هي قوات فاغنار تتحرك من
اوكرانيا صوب الداخل الروسي فيا له من
تغير كبير في المواقف بالامس يحاربون كتف
لكتف واليوم يتحاربون فيما بينهم وعلى حين
غفله واثناء هذا الارباك الحاصل في روسيا
اعلن قائد قوات فاغنار يافغيني بريكوجين
السيطره على المقر العسكري الروسي
فيروسطاف دون اطلاق رصاصه واحده من جهته
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لم طويلا
وخرج ليلقي كلمته للشعب الروسي فقال انما
نظم العصيان المسلح وصوب سلاحهم على
رفاقهم في القتال خان روسيا ووجهوا للشعب
الروسي طعنه في الظهر ولن يفلت من العقاب
في اشاره الى فاقنار ورئيسها
في اوكرانيا واضاف انهم سطروا البطولات في
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا ليخدم بوتين
بيانه بان السلطات الروسيه لن تسمح
بانقسام روسيا وستحرص على حمايه الشعب
وهناك امر بوتين سلاح الجو الروسي بفعل
اللازم للقضاء على من نظم التمرد المسلح
بوتين طلب من مقاتل فاجنر تسليم انفسهم
للجيش الروسي لا يرد قائد فاغنر على الفور
بان خطاب بوتين مخيب للامال مضيفا بان
بوتين اخطا ولن يستسلم احد من قوه فاغنار
ليطلق جمله قد تفجر الوضع بقوله انه قريبا
سيكون لروسيا رئيس
لكنه عاد وحذف هذه الجمله من حسابه
الداخل يغلي
ومجموعته دخلوا
الرئيس بوتان يصدر قانونا مشددا يسمح
للسلطات الروسيه باحتجاز اي شخص يخالف
القوانين العرفيه المعلنه في البلاد مده
30 يوما مقاطعه روستاف اصبحت في جراب
والعين ترمق العاصمه موسكو عمده موسكو
سوبيان يعلن يوم السادس والعشرين من يونيو
عطله في موسكو وقال عمده العاصمه ان هذا
يرجع الى الوضع الصعب نضيفا من اجل تقليل
المخاطر الى الحد الادنى اطلب منكم
بالامتناع عن التسكع في جميع انحاء
المدينه قدر الامكان من الممكن ايضا منع
حركه المرور في بعض الكتل وعلى طرق معينه
لكن ما قبل موسكو وقع انفجاران على الاقل
بالقرب من مقر قياده المنطقه العسكريه
الجنوبيه الروسيه في
واشتعلت النيرانو وتصاعدت الادخنه ليعود
الدور مره اخرى على
وهناك قال ان قواته اسقطت مروحيه اخرى
للجيش الروسي مضيفا اعيد واكرر تنبيه
الجميع سنسحق كل من يقف في طريقنا
وسنعتبركم اعداء لنا ولن تستطيع قتلنا
عددنا 25
وجميعنا مستعدون للموت والداخل يغلي حقا
يا ساده ليعود عمده
مجددا ويعلن عن تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه
وتشديد قيود مكافحه الارهاب في المدينه
والمدارس والخنادق والاتربه تحيط بمداخل
العاصمه والقوات تتاهب ولتهدئه الوضع وصلت
لجنه من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بقياده يونس
باكيه نائب وزير الدفاع وهناك قال لهم
بريجوجل انهم لا يطالبون بالتغيير بوتين
او السلطات بل بالعكس وما زالوا على راس
من يدعم اهداف العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا لكن لهم طلبات وشروط لن يتزحزح
عنها وعلى راسها اذا لم ياتي وزير الدفاع
الروسي ورئيس اركانه للقاء بريج وجنبي
فانهم سيزحفون الى موسكو وهو ما حدث فعلا
فقوه فاغنر سلكت الطريق المؤديه الى موسكو
لكن واثناء ذلك تم اجراء اغلاق واسع لمعظم
الطرقات الواصله الى موسكو لمحاوله تعطيل
تقدم المجموعه وذلك لا يعني بالضروره
انهيار شاملا على وشك الحدوث في روسيا فقد
تحدث مواجهه عسكريه بين الطرفين وقد يتم
نزع فتيل الازمه بطريقه او باخرى وهو ما
حاول رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
فعلا ولكن دعونا نعود لنكمل ما حدث على
الاراضي الروسيه حيث كان نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري ميدفيد افقد خرج
مصرحا بانه يبدو ان البلاد تواجه انقلابا
عسكريا مخططا ومن ومدروسا للاستيلاء على
السلطه في روسيا وفق تعبير
الخارج ليس كالداخل
الارباك في الداخل الروسي هي فرصه
للاوكرانيا لافراغ غضبهم نحو موسكو وهنا
كبير مستشاري الرئيس الاوكراني
يقول ان الساعات المقبله وضعت الراس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين امام خيارين فاما
انه سيوجه حربا اهليه في بلاده او انه
سيتفاوض على انتقال السلطه خلال 48 ساعه
انها يا صديقي مجرد احلام ورديه وفي موقف
غريب لم تستغل الولايات المتحده هذه
اللحظه الحرجه للروس حيث قالت صحيفه
تعتزم تاجيل فرض عقوبات جديده على فاجنر
حتى لا تبدو منحازه لاي طرف في روسيا
وهناك قالت موسكو صراحه وعلى خلفيه محاوله
التمرد المسلح وبلهجه مغلظه حيث ح وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه الدول الغربيه من اي
تلميحات الى احتمال استخدام الوضع الروسي
الداخلي لتحقيق اهدافها المعاديه لروسيا
فيما كان اول زعيم اجنبي يهدف بوتين هو
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والذي اعرب
عن دعمه الكامل للخطوات التي تتخذها
القياده الروسيه في تصدها للعصيان المسلح
الذي اعلنه قائد مجموعه
الليله الماضيه مع اعلان انقره استعدادا
الرئيس اردوغان شخصيا للوسطه للمملمه
الداخل الروسي
الفيلم البروتيني
هنا المخرج يقول هاستار الرئيس البالروسي
الكسندر لوكاشينكو يعلن ان بريكوجين قبل
بالمقترح البيلاروسي واعلن انسحابه من
جميع المواقع وهي لها هذه الحرب الخادعه
والتي كانت قصيره جدا لدرجه ان الحاقدين
لم يخرجوا شماتتهم وحقدهم بعد لتعلن
رويترز بان الطباخ اعلن في رساله صوتيه
اعاده مقاتله الى قواعدهم حقنا للدماء
لتعود بذلك الى المعسكرات الميدانيه وكما
حدثناكم عندما بدات احداث ثوره فاغنار
القصيره فان هذا قد يكون فخا لاكتشاف
الجواسيس والخونه في الداخل الروسي فكل
شخص في هذا الخلاف سيطفو الى السطح ليصبح
في الواجهه امام الرئيس الروسي ليقدمهم
بريجوج كقربان لبوتين وسيعلن حينها عن
تصفيه روسيا من الخونه المتربصين بالبلاد
حتى اذا اشتد الضغط من الداخل والخارج لن
يكون هناك مكان لل خونه في بلاد الدب
الروسي فهل حقق بوتين غايته وهل عرف بوتين
من يقف بجانبه ومن يقف ضده
[موسيقى]